so it seems that zoom court has struck
once again poor
judge middleton who seems has to deal
with all of the worst cases
who dealt with the accuser who was in
the same room as the accused
with the person who was dealing with a
suspended license while zooming from
a car is now dealing with this yahoo
your name's not butt 3000 you
yoho yes that is definitely not his real
name it seems that the judge
saw that the username was something i
can't say
but he was not amused the person who was
making a court appearance clearly had no
idea what was going on seemed contrite
i don't believe that i typed anything
like that in this is a misunderstanding
poor judge middleton has seen everything
here he excoriates the person for
not checking your zoom username come on
we've been doing zoom hearings for over
a year now
you've got to check your username before
you sign into court think about
what you call yourself online and gave
him a timeout to think about what he's
done so i guess we'll see this guy
back in court you yoho